the faster Furious franchise as famous
for as high octane car chases and
spectacular crashes but all those world
sons reallyá-- stained dress as they
look absolutely stunt driver and
coordinator Robert Nagel who has worked
on every installment in the Fast &
Furious series since Fast Five and
recently over sword are thrilling racing
scenes in James Mangold's
oscar-nominated film Ford versus Ferrari
spoke with looper in an exclusive
interview about his career before he
became a stunt driver he worked as a
racer though he switched careers when
money became too big of a factor Nagel
explained going down the back
straightaway at 280 miles an hour and
you were trying to think about where the
next check is coming from it just takes
away from the passion of the sport this
is why Nagel tends to not worry about
whether or not he and his fellow drivers
are up to the task a lot of the guys I
hire have a pretty solid race background
because I know I can put them in any car
sales sometimes even the best drivers
can lose control Ford versus Ferraris
most spectacular car crash which occurs
as Christian Bale's can miles completes
his very first lap at the 24 Hours of
LeMans was based on a real-life event
before working on Ford versus Ferrari
the film second unit director Darren
Prescott was participating in a
celebrity race when another car fell
apart right in front of him it was a
right hand corner and the car went a
little bit wide and dropped the outside
wheels into the grass and that send the
car sideways and shot it back across the
track and it hits a concrete wall
Prescott was pretty certain he just saw
somebody die luckily Prescott was wrong
and the other driver was fine when it
came time to film Ford versus Ferrari
Nagle and Prescott decided to recreate
that crash in the movie however the
funnel scene isn't there just for
thrills but to show how dangerous LeMond
is after all the wreck comes during the
first four minutes of miles race when he
still has 24 hours to go on set though
the real danger often comes from factors
outside of the stunt teams control when
asked to identify his most dangerous
stunts on the Fast & Furious films Magel
explained that almost everything is
inherently and safe saying there's so
much going on with some of these there
are multiple cars and explosions
pyrotechnics going off around us there's
a whole lot going on and a whole lot
that can go wrong very quickly still
when pressed Nagle singled out one fast
and furious scene that was especially
dangerous the opening of fast and
furious 6 which he described as pretty
in the sequence dominic toretto played
by Vin Diesel and Brian O'Conner played
by Paul Walker race on a twisty Spanish
road in order to get home before Brian's
girlfriend Mia played by Jordana
Brewster gives birth on one side is a
sheer rock cliff on the other nothing
but ocean the scene was filmed on
location in Tenerife the largest of the
Canary Islands nagels and the camera car
filming the action while former top gear
driver Ben Collins Andrade car champion
Mark Higgins did the actual racing as
Nagel explains the driving wasn't the
problem
the road was there was this road that
they wanted me to go shoot that was
deemed too dangerous for the general
public to drive on it's got a thousand
foot drop off into the ocean with his
little blocks that will probably slow
you down just enough so he gets a really
good look of where you're about to crash
this time it ain't just about being a
fast
[Music]
in addition to the terrain of the road
itself there was another hazard that no
amount of careful planning or skill
could account for according to Nagel I
commented to the guys some really bad
potholes on that road somebody said to
me you know those aren't potholes those
are divots from rocks
they've been falling off the cliff on
the other side of you that's a thousand
feet up as if the road conditions
weren't already dangerous enough Nagle
also had to navigate it to full speed
without any practice while Collins and
Higgins have been racing for a week by
the time they film the stunt
it was Nagle's first day at work Nagle
admitted to very top drivers that have
been driving this road for the last week
and I've got to chase him down with this
camera car yeah it was a little scary
fortunately Nichols skill and experience
paid off and he was able to film the
scene in one take check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]